People are playing Azula wrong. Well,
kind of. Imagine being my friend Jimmy.
He's had a crush on Azula since puberty.
Uh, I can fix that.
Pay off. Hoop.
We just jump through the hoop and
profit, right? Simple enough. And that's
the typical Azula build I see, but the
problem is we have maybe 10, 12 other
commanders that do the same with
different hoops, some easier, some
harder. So, unless you're obsessed with
Azula like Jimmy is, what sets her apart
from the other spell-doubling
commanders?
To be fair, if you give them flash,
being able to copy creatures and
enchantments is pretty sweet, especially
for Grixis. But, yeah, having to go
through all this trouble just to dump
your hand and make a massive board
during your combat phase seems a bit
restrictive. But, why not go with rather
than against the flow? I'm sure Uncle
Iroh has some words of wisdom about
this.
A crumbly biscuit is not a problem. It's
just a chance to enjoy the pieces.
Something like that. But, anyways, what
does Azula want to do? Azula wants to
beat people up, and that's what we're
doing today. Voltron, combat, spell
double. Double again seems good. Hello,
this is Jin with Next Level Commander. I
post regular Commander content, and
there are some really interesting
choices from this Avatar set. So, please
subscribe if you're interested. Also,
there are so many new legends nowadays,
it's easy to gloss over some interesting
ones. Are there any hidden gems that you
found from this set or any other? Please
let me know in the comments.
So, let's take a look at Azula. Four
mana 4/4, not great. Could be better.
Fire bending is cool, but it's such a
specific and narrow mechanic. But, we'll
make full use of it. And finally, spell
copying during combat, and this is what
we are building around. The main idea is
simple. These pump spells that can
double up combined with pretty much any
other pump spell, we can straight up
one-shot an opponent. Now, let's take a
look. Starting off with the best ones,
bulk up and unleash fury. Being able to
double and double again for two mana,
you're dealing 16 damage to someone
without any other pump. With anything
else, even a plus one spell cuz those
are also copied. We are going for
lethal. Doubling is so good here. Even a
double trouble is worth the mana. And
once in a while it can pump multiple
relevant attackers, Azula and Ink-Moth
Nexus for example. Aside from the
doublers, another hidden gem is Fist of
Flame. On his own we are drawing two
cards and pumping Azula for five, but
often times it's double or even triple
that because of how much we're drawing.
For the less efficient pump spells, they
are doing more. Double strike for
instance is a bit redundant when copied.
Same with Great Train Heist. But those
cards provide enough value in other ways
to justify their inclusion. And also
these ones either paying for themselves,
drawing us cards, or stick around as an
equipment. Twinferno specifically is
used to copy spells twice usually,
making whatever I cast next happen four
times when combined with Azula. See the
day can't be copied, but it's just an
auto include in any Voltron deck getting
three combats you can kill three
opponents often times. And finally we
sprinkle in a few of the super efficient
one mana plus three, I mean six, into
the mix and that's our pump package.
Azula's biggest weakness is the cost.
Four is not cheap, especially for a deck
that doesn't do much without his
commander. But fortunately four is the
easiest cost to ramp up to. I mean just
play two mana rocks and we've got the
whole suite.
The only three mana option here is
Misleading Signpost because flash. We
can cast this while attacking and get
two rocks for three mana. That's decent.
Now Azula is the kind of commander that
is worth devoting a lot of resources
into protecting because she will pay us
back. How? With these little draw spells
that become ridiculous when copied. The
only thing better than discarding one to
draw four for two mana is discarding one
to draw four for zero mana. All these
draw ones are super reasonable as well
for their cost and the utility they
give. Born Upon a Wind isn't relevant
too often, but flashing in a few mana
rocks that pay for themselves is decent.
And flashing in a commander is another
way of protecting her. Take through time
will almost always cost two mana and
will dig us 16 deep. Almost guaranteed
to turn into a kill or two. Try to leave
one instant in the graveyard as you
delve because there's a decent chance
that you will get a gear hulk or
something similar and it might just be
the best choice.
And it's not really a deck tech on this
channel without some protection spells.
Azula is not cheap and the deck revolves
around her too much for us to just leave
her out there to get removed. So, we
have the typical reanimate and efficient
counter spells. Fungal fortitude and
faith flight are cool since enchantments
are also copied. So, a permanent pump /
evasion can be useful on top of being
protection spells. Cryptic command is
versatile in being a counter spell or an
evasion spell in a pinch. And now this
is quite an all in deck because we are
not as fast as decks like Vivi or Ezio.
So, we still need to play some
interaction and removals. Our counter
spell suite is solid and for removals
we're trying to avoid the ones that
leave a blocker behind for our
opponents. Instead, we have some
synergistic ones like Asterion's thirst
which will kill two things and pump our
commander to 10 plus power just for four
mana. And snap which also serves as a
ritual with the untapping. And finally,
some miscellaneous utility specifically
made for Azula. She has no evasion so
that will be a challenge. Leap and
shadow rift both give evasion and double
can trip. Silver scroll costume is both
a protection spell and evasion. Just
watch out for the shroud. Make sure we
get our pump in before the shroud kicks
in. Torrential gear hulk is amazing. You
get two copies of the gear hulk which
will bring back two instants from the
grave and each of those will be copied.
Mission briefing and snapcaster mage are
a bit similar especially if one of the
spells you flashback is something like
turnabout which lets you mana. And yet
turnabout is nuts. It's usually a
massive ritual but can also be evasion
in a pinch. Increasing vengeance will
copy spell twice when cast from hand but
if you flash it back you get four copies
of any instant. And finally, tidal
barracuda. It gives everything notably
our commander flash, but more
importantly it serves as a weaker grand
abolisher. With this on the field, you
can pretty much kill whoever you want
without worrying about counter plays.
For lands, we focus on mana fixing with
the key utilities being haste and
evasion. And for haste, we're only
playing the ones that don't cost extra
mana. Arena of glory is the best one of
the bunch. Command beacon is there in
case Azula gets too expensive. Talisman
gates of Madera will phase Azula out and
guarantee that we get to untap with her.
And Inkmoth Nexus is our alternative win
condition. And there you have the deck.
Voltron is always a bit awkward to play
in four player. You should be able to
take out an opponent fairly quickly, but
if you do that, there's a good chance
you are keeping someone out of the game
for a long duration and you might get
hated out as well. So, the ideal play
pattern is chipping down opponents in
early game while sculpting our hand to
set up for one shotting the biggest
threat when the time comes. But with how
explosive Azula is, once she's
attacking, it might be difficult to hold
back. Even on your first attack on say
turn four, you'll be drawing into more
draw and just stumble upon 22 damage and
hit. All during combat. And you will
have to decide whether to hold off or
just go for it. Either way, this isn't a
deck for everyone or every group. It
isn't the most explosive, but I'd say
it's still mid to high. A bit glass
cannony for its reliance on Azula. It
can be quite complex to pilot. Almost
feels like half a storm deck. And the
decision tree can be massive. It's
fairly budget friendly. The core of the
deck is the cheap pump spells and draw
spells and all the expensive stuff I
have on my list are pretty replaceable.
The list is down in the in the
descriptions. And technically, it is a
bracket three. And there you go, the
Azula Voltron deck. She's probably one
of the most potent fighters in the
series and this deck hopes to reflect
that. This is Jin with Next Level
Commander and once again, they're
releasing so many legendaries now and
it's easy to miss all the interesting
takes and interesting builds as I gloss
through them. So, if there's a commander
that you see from the new sets, Avatar,
Eldraine, or what's it called? March of
the Machine: The Aftermath. Yeah, you
think it has potential? Let me know in
the comments, and it might just be the
next deck I build.
All right, thanks for watching. See you.